hollywood harmier uh j.d is going out to
la for the super bowl and blit are you
going out there with him i think you're
going to be covering them right yeah i'm
totally psyched gary is working on
getting jd into some of the exclusive
big parties with all the famous people
so i'm talking to jake you got to hear
jd what a player this guy is
proud of him this morning he goes uh uh
and he i knew he wanted to tell me
something but he was having trouble
getting it out more trouble than he
usually does and he goes uh
uh and when i'm out there uh there's a
whole bunch of parties and i don't mean
to drop the names but
uh ryan phillippe is getting me into the
party he's gonna yeah
i go who's getting you into the party
ryan phillippe i mean listen he called
me
uh you know we usually text if anything
but uh that was very nice of him he's a
very uh
he's a very good guy and as soon as you
said that everyone jumped in with the
new name hollywood harmier well john
hyde you know that's sean hines [ __ ]
thing it's been for years any time i
talk about like interacting with a
celebrity of any sort it's oh hollywood
hartmire hollywood harmer over there i'm
working on i don't know if i can pull
this off i'm working on getting jd into
the commissioner's dinner it's this big
party the year i went when kansas city
was in there not only were the owners
there the the owner's hot daughter but
um any celebrity that loves the chiefs
will be there so the bengals booth would
be amazing for jd to be every owners
there every player can you imagine if
you get into that party with as gary
says the owners and their hot daughter
[ __ ] he's talking about
all the owners and their hot daughter
will be there like the owners had a
daughter yeah like all the owners gave
birth to one daughter
howard it is the party with the owners
and the beautiful daughter
the very famous jerry o'connell tweeted
jd offering to let him sleep at his
place do you want to sleep at jerry's
house
i love jerry i i wouldn't mind seeing
jerry but i don't i'm not staying at
this house i'm not you don't want to
stay at his house why not i don't like
imposing myself in people's houses he's
inviting him
he's inviting you no but still he's
inviting you and blit over to the house
to sleep there do we need to take you
shopping for clothes like pretty woman
style getting
oh i don't know you know i have clothes
i'm definitely bringing my bengals
jersey but you know i'm not wasn't
playing what about these parties jd you
don't wear
that shirt he can't go meet the owners
and their hot daughter wearing that
shirt
you can tell gary's been thinking about
that daughter ever since then
it's on his mind how it's the place to
be is all the owners and their hot
daughter
that was like two or three years ago
gary well how did you reject jerry i
didn't well i i didn't reject jerry
what did you say what did you tell him
so i don't want to come to your house
thank you for now for i appreciate it
hot [ __ ] harmer
it's the hot [ __ ] don't stink